it's like you know Martin Luther King's
one of my heroes but he also cheated on
his wife a lot I was saying I talked to
this lady I met her at a conference and
she worked for Google but or like big
thing inside of Google what's called
Google Labs or something where they'll
do like a hundred million in revenue or
something but they're like it's too
small like it won't move the needle they
just really yeah that's surprising
I'm I don't believe that I'd love to
hear which ones of these projects that
they had got to do she told me that uh
she's like it's like we don't know how
big it can get so we're just gonna kill
it and she also said that they had a
hard time finding leaders because the
people who they would have were people
who had started companies in the past
and they just paid them so much at
Google that they were like like I don't
go right here yeah there's a pretty cool
story about have you heard about the
Cisco spin-out spin in model no so so a
lot of companies try to do these like
innovation labs innovation arms
innovation blah blah blah you know just
a lot of it's just like kind of PR puff
but the companies genuinely they do want
to innovate right why would they not but
it's really hard for them and Cisco is
one of the few companies that's done
this really well where they have
incubated and they do what they call
spin out spin in multiple businesses
that have been worth over a billion
dollars to Cisco and so I was like how
the hell did I do that and what they
have is they have this little group of I
think for people who have now since left
but they're this group of four that were
there for god knows how many years
fifteen twenty years something like that
and they called them some nickname I
don't know I'm gonna make it up called
the M group or something like that it's
at the em team and what they would do is
they'd have some idea or they would you
did that team would have an idea or the
company would have an idea and they
would spin out to this group so they
were their own company they would get
their own little office they would build
this product they would they would build
it up and Cisco would have the right to
just rebuy it for like five hundred
million dollars whenever they're ready
whenever whatever they view it's ready
and so there's a whole bunch of
so that same team did this three or four
times that same group of four or five
people they went out built the thing
spun back in and they did it again and
again and now they've actually left and
the that group of people I think they're
just doing their own thing but if you
want to look it up I should have looked
it up before this but I didn't know we
were gonna talk about it but who's on
that cat table I think it's just those
four people and Cisco itself or
something like that I don't know how I
don't know it's like works starting
companies with a buyer in mind with well
you are though you have the right to buy
I have the right to buy back VC I forget
who it was and he's like I don't really
I typically don't invest in companies
when they like havoc and exit plan in
mine like because I want them to because
I think that then they're not in it for
the right reasons but he goes he goes
one time I did do that I invested in
this guy and he said this company is
gonna buy us probably in 36 months
because we're gonna build something they
can't build and I'm gonna operate faster
them and end up becoming true right all
right so here's the article
Business Insider article why cisco
showered these three men with billions
and of course it's like behind a paywall
but the basis do we know them frame
somebody Mario Missoula and now we I
don't know them they're older they're
all older they're not sort of I don't
think they're in sort of like the same
scene that we we roll in but but yeah it
worked for a while and then now they
they stopped doing it I think some
companies have tried to replicate it but
it hasn't worked for them I'm not sure
exactly why but you know if you could
figure out how to help big companies
innovate there's obviously a lot of
money to be had there so um before we
get into this I gotta ask the listeners
and you something so Jack our friend
Jack Smith introduced me to this guy a
few years ago and I don't even want to
say with the services yeah but babe okay
I think I could say a little bit there's
a ride-sharing service one of the
ride-sharing services and what this guy
does is he had I think this is how he
does it I don't exactly know but you can
buy discounted credits right you know
how
I paid 20 bucks and I get $40 worth of
rides have you done it so he showed it
to me years ago all right this is like I
don't know how long two years ago maybe
he said it to us and I was like oh great
I take rides all the time would love to
then as I went through the website I was
like is this like us a is this a scam I
don't think so because Jack said he's
doing any recommended it I've done it
but then I was like is this gonna get my
account banned like this is too good to
be true so my skepticism went off iced I
didn't do it I forgot about it and then
he post about it in the you know private
my first million Facebook group he said
hey did you guys know about this is a
really cool clever hacking system that
this guy's created Jack loves those
things that's tell me more about what's
got your high here yeah so first of all
Sean turn your mic up just a little bit
I think yeah say something hold on just
a little right abraao he's got to turn
it up a little bit and put it okay I
turned it up is that better much better
okay so he asked his service now he's
doing it for similar things and okay so
Jack was like hey you should have this
guy on the podcast and I'm like okay so
pros this guy is a hustler he's doing
amazing stuff and I'm pretty sure I
think he's either said it or I figured
it out I'm pretty sure the way he does
it this guy's in India I think what he
does is he has a network I'm like
thousands of teenagers and kids and he
just gives them a first ride on on on a
ride service and he gets the $10 back
like in referral and then sells it
either that he's gaming the exists it's
not as far as I understand it's not like
illegal there's no like sort of illicit
hacking everything he just says hey they
have a referral system which is cool you
get a you know every time you refer
somebody to get certain amount of
credits and what he realizes he can do
cheaper maybe shorter rides in India and
that will count as a new customer that's
been referred and so he can give you in
the u.s. you know your full credit for a
lightweight right there and the
arbitrage there's some money he keeps
some money and we get a saving and then
the ride the person who takes the ride
he gets a free ride so it's like a
win-win-win for everybody but the
service and to add to complexity if you
with Bitcoin you get a bigger discount
and if you like do XYZ like it's it's it
looks incredibly shady long story short
it's interesting it's a cool story it's
definitely it's not a scam but it's
questionable about the ethics and so do
we want to promote this or not um yeah
of course I stopped promoting it I am
interested in this guy's story and I
think a lot of people be interested in
it you can make your own judgement after
you hear them out as to for promoting
unethical behavior yeah but people call
you for whatever I I don't think we're
promoting anything it's one thing okay
it's promoting if we say this is awesome
go do this okay that's fair but that's
an opinion right but I think the right
thing to do is to say hey here's
somebody who's doing something
interesting they are they found a way to
hustle and create you know create a
business for themselves as well as value
for others we should hear them out and
then let people judge for themselves
is this like past the gray area and not
not cool for them or is this actually
like you know fine and so I think I
think that's we should leave that up to
the listener but our job is to tell the
story and also I'm curious so why not
have a mom who cares a journalist
alright well uh he's met he message to
unite well we'll set it up I don't even
know if he speaks English well enough I
guess we'll find out right yeah we'll
find out we'll bring him on so I had
some other of these these are more like
actual scams but I wanted to talk about
them I don't know why I wanted to just
tell you some things that I've seen okay
so recently I don't know if you've seen
on YouTube or if it's just in my
recommendations but all day every day
there's a live stream of shamov poly
Hypatia who's kind of like a known
investor early Facebook guy billionaire
it's like Chamath talking about bitcoin
and it has always like 40 50 thousand
live viewers watching it at any given
time and it says bitcoin giveaway Jamaa
fit coin giveaway and what they did so
what someone's doing which is just
totally a scam they have a stream going
they have a video embedded of Chi Minh
talking about Bitcoin from like five
years ago it's not Tremont's doing this
by the way
he's trying to get a cook and then on
the screen it says Bitcoin giveaway send
me your address and I'll send Bitcoin to
somebody and I think they're just making
money off the ad revenue of this live
stream and it has like 40 50 thousand
people I'm sure some of that spot
traffic and some of it is real traffic
but it's hilarious that somebody's doing
this like a what a waste of time and B
it's hilarious that YouTube allows this
tomas trying to take it down but okay so
that's one little thing I noticed here's
another one
you know when the US government came out
with the kind of PPP like hey if you're
unemployed or you're an employer and you
have people you can get access to money
so of course the Nigerian sort of
scammers came out and they actually took
out a hundred million dollars from the
system I don't know if you heard about
this they just filed as either
unemployed people or or employers of
unemployed people or sorry employers who
pay the sort of Nigerian scam ring it's
only what's it's called the 409 scam I
think it's called is that the name of
the program is that like the country
code of so a lot of these guys are based
on a Lagos Nigeria I think and I think
and I believe that they're there because
for some reason it's part of I don't
know how it got embedded into that
particular culture where they're where
they it became a thing but I think I
also think that there's a not really
strict laws around like there's a lot of
loopholes in law that you can not get
punished so this guy totally scammed are
these these group of people scammed out
a hundred million dollars out of the
government
yeah the u.s. government well the US
government was giving away money for
like in a really intense two week three
week frenzy abreu just linked some guy
in from Wikipedia Emmanuel mudiay I
don't know how you say his name but he
sold an airport for 240 million dollars
he didn't own this Airport which is
crazy so there's that and that here's
some other ones that I thought were
interesting so you know super PACs like
the political fundraising thing which
sort of like gets around the normal
donation limits for yeah it's like a
it's like a it's like they like form a
company or a fun and
give money to the fund and that funds
allowed to donate a larger larger
quantity of money right so they're super
PACs for every cause so my my friend
who's my friend Jason had this hilarious
idea he didn't do this but he was just
like he's very politically minded and he
hated super PACs cuz he's like oh god
like it's the super PACs who get behind
let's say the gun lobby or whoever that
like fund these things that I don't
agree with necessarily and I just think
super PACs are kind of shady there's
lack of transparency blah blah and then
he sort of had this idea of like if you
can't beat him join him so he was like I
know what I'll do and I thought this is
a hilarious idea he's like for every
issue I'm just gonna spin up to super
PACs one taking each side and I'm just
gonna raise all the money again for both
sides and I'm gonna take a cut for every
issue
he's like until they shut that super
PACs and I thought that was a hilarious
way to fight super PACs didn't uh do you
remember at founders dojo where I used
to work out of it was like this office
that was kind of like Erlich Bachman on
the TV show Silicon Valley I think Dave
did something like this where he created
a a donation thing who was running Trump
versus Oba Trump versus Hillary and he
created like D like created something
where he was like pledged support to
Hillary and then he also had a pledge of
support for okay yeah exactly there's
all kinds of crazy stuff I don't know I
don't know why I needed to bring up a
bunch of fake scams what what's
wealthiest person who you know who got
money off of like a shady way
I gotta think about that do you have one
I don't know if this is shady but I have
a bunch of friends that have made a lot
of money like 30 40 50 million dollars
off of what I consider to be borderline
unethical internet marketing practices
like for example who have run call
centers like you know how you get a
phone call from like Marriott hotels
it's not really from area it's like or
you know if you I knew a guy who had a
company hold on it's not really for
Marriott and then what I don't know how
the scam works so I get the calls all
the time but they'll say like you know
you won this you won like it's basically
they're selling you travel packages it's
like you were picked from a random
drawing to get a discount on a all
exclusive trip to sandals so that's not
unethical it's just obnoxious and then I
know a guy who made a bunch of money off
a CO registration company so like when
you sign up on Expedia they sell your
email address to 18 other travel stuff
and he was the middleman and he made
like 50 million dollars embed it all on
in the stock market in one big okay
the closest the first thing that came to
mind or the closest thing that came on I
don't actually know this person but I
you know no no the guy's kid and and
this is the dad
so there's guide intervene Jane who oh I
know him CEO of this thing called
InfoSpace back in the day and it like
during the.com boom InfoSpace was like
you know riding high and then you know
sort of overnight InfoSpace
crashes but he had sort of sold out or
you know protected his own interest
right before the crash and was like you
know everybody lost their jobs in their
401ks and the company and this guy was
like a billionaire and so that was sort
of shady and then he started this thing
called intelligent
I think that's the name of it yeah and
it had a similar outcome yeah Telly's is
this like shady thing where you would
sign up for a free credit check I think
or it's like back you find information
from public records about people or
about yourself
I don't remember exactly what the what
the product was cuz I don't spend too
much time you know like think about the
stuff but basically there was this tiny
checkbox at the bottom which was like
cool you got this free credit check but
then we're gonna charge you 20 bucks a
month just kind of on subscription after
that for blah blah some [__] and so
they were making millions and millions
of dollars and people were all like wait
what am i get I just paid like two
hundred dollars this year for Intel yes
what does that mean what is this and
people kind of screenshotted the flow
and showed how like you know size for
font the the fine print was that you're
gonna get charged for this thing and so
that was pretty bad yeah that guy claims
to be a billionaire yeah exactly
he's a pretty like kind of crazy
charismatic guy he's now got this like
company that's about going to the moon
like a rockets company and all kinds of
stuff but he's definitely you know
behind that smile there's definitely
like some skeletons or some baggage like
you know neither of those two two
stories InfoSpace or I think it's called
int Elias
neither of those seemed like the most
up-and-up companies well let's talk
about some legit companies right after
our podcast Monday I went and bought a
car
you committed I love it if anything
take-take-take inspiration from the
massive immediate action that that Sam
and hopefully may take whenever we say
we're gonna do something we just go
commit and just do it right away yeah I
uh like I made the decision Saturday I
bought a car Monday I just went like I
showed up to buy the car and I was like
yeah I guess I'll take that one and
they're like how do you want to pay for
it house like oh I shouldn't even think
about it and they just took a debit card
right okay so so let's do some other
companies or some other ideas that you
got what else you got otherwise I have a
couple we can do we did a ton of
research that we didn't even get to last
time so once you I pull I have our sheet
up why don't you kick it off alright so
I'll do one so this one actually comes
also from Jack so this is sort of the
Jack episode he's the guest but we don't
have him here so he was talking a little
bit about baseball cards and I know
baseball cards are hot right now cuz
Gary Vee he's been really pumping
baseball cards and talk about baseball
cards all
and so baseball cards are like a
collector's item they hunt they have
value they appreciate overtime it's you
know like many many goods of that kind
now one thing that's a common problem
for people who are buying selling and
trading baseball cards is the actual
receiving of that you know you receive a
shipment you have to open it up you hope
it's not damaged you have to verify that
it's real and then if you sell it you
got a sort of go through that whole
shipping process right back to the other
person hope that nothing goes wrong in
the process and so for people who are
collecting these as a sort of financial
asset in some ways and they don't
they're not like sitting there trying to
carry them with them to school or
something like that you don't need the
physical card he was saying why is there
not sort of a central repository where
you can like a like a safety deposit a
Fort Knox for for the baseball cards
where basically you buy and sell it
online but it never moves it just sort
of exchanges ownership but it's all
stored in this central vault where it's
cooled properly so they don't degrade
they're all verified by a professional
there who is centrally located you don't
have to deal with any of the shipping
costs or potential issues there so I see
the headline to you the Fort Knox of
baseball cards yes I think is a pretty
clever idea and obviously could extend
to sneakers could extend to art could
extend to other things maybe there's
something that like this that exists I
don't do baseball cards or art do you
dabble with any of this stuff um I got
into shoes after I learned about him we
wrote about it on trends of about a year
ago and I've since gotten into them yeah
but not to the point of wanting to make
money off of it but to the point of like
spending $300 on a pair but I did do
research on this and it seems as though
there's not a great solution so Jack's
on to something we wrote about this
actually heritage auction house what I
would do if I wanted to create this
which I actually think this is a
wonderful idea I don't I don't I
certainly don't have time so I'm not
going to but this is a great idea and
what I would maybe do is contact a lot
of the auction houses and be like what
are you guys doing now right what why
can't this work and or collectors you
know high-end collectors people who have
a portfolio of these things because I
think it is a very small it's a small
it's a
nice community obviously dismembers
leaves you think well just that's like a
depends on your reference point right so
it's like in all of society yeah it's
super nice but in terms like how many
people do you think are actively
investing in or trading baseball cards
right like is it in the tens of
thousands people I'm saying like
potential customers you have to convince
to use your service hundreds of
thousands hundreds okay that's it well I
would I would bet it's lower like and
the reason why is like for there's
always a long tail of really casual
people but of people who actively do it
and have like some you know above let's
call it $200 worth of value locked in it
you know like Shopify has like 50,000
ish or it did two years ago when I
looked at this maybe it's a hundred
thousand now power sellers Etsy sort of
in that same range twitch has like in be
fifty thousand ish partners sorry I
don't think there's a hundred thousand
sellers I think that there's a hundred
thousand people who are interested in
transacting in this market right right
and so I think you could get I think my
point is that the kind of circle of
influence is pretty tight here where the
number of people you would need to
convince and that you could go learn
from to see if this is a real problem
it's kind of small and that's great it's
like kind of like online poker where you
just go get these fifteen pros to do
something and now they sway the rest of
the casual community with them as like
oh yeah that's the best practice that's
how we do things now it's pretty
interesting and I love it and I like its
I wonder I would have to imagine this
has significantly better economics or
maybe not in storage so do you know how
the companies like clutter are doing I
always assume that those companies are
on the verge of failure now I don't know
if they because and I think Omni
actually it's like everything's going
great we keep raising money we keep
adding high-profile people and we shut
down like that's how these companies
tend to go or they they break out you
know but you know that public storage
you know the company public storage is
huge yeah it's the most profitable
company on the stock market is that
right by cool claim is that my margin so
it like does four billion in revenue and
like two billion in net income
interesting yeah it's like the most
profitable thing now they don't do what
they don't do all this high cost [__]
that all the new startups do or they
like want to bring you your stuff they
just say like here's a room bring my
stuff it's yours give us $100 a month
[Music]
but it could be a it's a really cool
idea I that's my point and so also other
thing I'm sure a lot of people know this
but I was ignorant I didn't know this
but these storage companies the real
estate businesses yes but it's just a
it's just a way to get profit to buy
real estate a great book I read when I
was in college that inspired me I was
like on the verge of going down the real
estate track rather than an
entrepreneurial track or the sort of
started B track and it's called
confessions of a real estate
entrepreneur it's an awesome book if
you're a total newb and you're just
curious about how the hell do people
make money it's not about the terms and
the tactics and all that stuff it's this
one guy being like I wanted to make it
real estate so then so he's like my
first deal I had no money and I found
this warehouse and then it negotiated
this and he just walks through deal by
deals for like ten deals of confessions
of a real estate entrepreneur and one of
them was about storage and you know the
whole game with real estate is you sort
of need to see value where others don't
so other people look at this twenty five
thousand square foot store warehouse and
they say ok warehouses are valued at X
dollars per square foot so this building
is worth at why and what you need to say
is hey if I subdivided this warehouse
it's just tiny storage units and I add
it all up now it's worth you know X plus
y dollars per square foot is more it's
worth more so I can go buy it I can
actually pay more than that I next to me
cuz I'm gonna I know I can get more
value out of it than that person can
because I know how to change use or add
value in some way that's what we work
did they took office floors and say hey
what if he subdivided it and rented this
out by the desk and so that's like a
common real estate strategy that's what
storage units are and if anyone
listening to this I think some people
will get mad at me I don't give a [__]
real estate has the highest ratio of
rich and dumb people like right how do
you what you
what I'm saying wearily what you're
saying it's got the highest ratio of low
IQ rich people this very doesn't mean if
you do real estate you're like here it
means there are more wealthy people in
real estate who are not superstar
geniuses who you know work them storm'll
working people like a normal smart
rational person who obviously had some
skills took some risks but there are
more wealthy people in real estate that
way if you just said hey Sean you know
in the next 10 years you die if you
don't get wealthy I'd be like cool go
into real estate
like that's my best path my highest
likelihood chance of becoming wealthy is
through real estate versus any other
sort of venture yeah it's the highest
the highest dumb people to rich people
job I've ever seen in my life I love it
ok so that's my that's that's Jack's
Jack's idea which is sort of Fort Knox
for baseball cards I like it what else
we got um let's go to uh we're gonna
talk about hey did we talk about hey I
don't think we did we didn't go for it
ok by the way this look at what I'm
drinking here I drink these all day
Heineken zero point zero it's called
Heineken zero it's not nine out it's not
the same it's not alcoholic beer it's
zero alcohol beer I've been drinking
these all day they're awesome
wait what do you mean it's not the same
as non-alcoholic difference I don't know
the legality but the I drink a lot of
non-alcoholic beer because I like beer
the normal non alcoholic beer says it
has less than 0.5% alcohol this has zero
point zero and Heineken said that this
is their fastest-growing category and
you like it I love it
I drink I'll drink for a day so what's
in it that makes it taste it does it
taste like beer or it tastes like
something else it's a it's a they call
it a malt and yeast beverage it's a
unique recipe it has 0% alcohol is
brewed with pure malt and special a
yeast just like the original Heineken
lager beer it has the same taste but
without the alcohol that's hilarious
they sell the same product with without
the expensive ingredient in charge the
same for it like here well let's give
you less
ingredients water malted barley hop
extract and natural flavor that's all it
is so oh man I love these I drink my
crazy
they're awesome okay we apparently we
did talk about hay a little bit but what
did you want to talk about uh I just
wanted to sort of call out the the sort
of marketing side of things of what they
do so have you read the book rework
which is there the 37signals book years
ago but they basically say that like one
of the marketing principles that they
talked about is like to have an enemy
right yeah I think there's a chapter
called pick a fight and I want to read
it so let me see if I can pull it up
real quick hold on to give you two
seconds
and I don't know if you do this but I do
it all but here's the here's the like
summary of the thing okay so should I
should have pulled I should have pulled
up my book before I did this hold on
okay so here's a section of it if you
think a competitor sucks say so when you
do that you'll find others who agree
with you and rally to your side being
the anti blank is a great way to
differentiate yourself and attract
followers for example Dunkin Donuts
position itself as the anti Starbucks it
it's ads mock Starbucks for using you
know these fake Italian words you know
instead of just saying small medium
large or they'll do a campaign like they
made a site called Dunkin beat Starbucks
com where visitors can send e-cards with
statements like friends don't let
friends drink Starbucks howdy is another
example it takes on the old guard of car
manufacturers it puts old and old luxury
brands like rolls-royce and Mercedes on
notice by touting how it's a fresh
alternative Apple jabs at Microsoft with
ads that compare Mac and PC owners etc
etc all these examples show the power
and direction you can gain by having a
target in your sights who do you want to
take a shot at you can even pit yourself
as the opponent of an entire industry
Dyson Airblade starts with the premise
that the hand-dryer industry itself is a
failure and it tells and then positions
to help as a faster more hygienic option
I can't believe it's not butter puts in
puts the enemy right in its own name
having an enemy gives you a great story
to tell your customers taking a stand
always stands out people get stoked by
conflict they take sides
passions are ignited it's a good way to
get people to take notice what do you
think picking an enemy yeah I'm down I
right now my enemies New York Times a
little bit and basically the media and
people journalists who say they don't
have a bias button like they can't admit
they do so yeah I'm down with that
and with hey calm I call it hey calm I
think it's working well I think that um
so they picked who I think initially
they picked just traditional email like
Gmail as the enemy for being like
cluttered you just keep getting spammed
by random things email you don't want
it's a headache you know now wait for
the Apple and now they picked Apple and
it was a way better fight to pick
because it's a more novel story and it
doesn't seem as self-serving as when
they pick Gmail is the competitor and I
like
that I actually like these guys a lot
and so I'm gonna talk [__] about him a
little bit but in general I really like
them and I respect them but I do think
that it's a little lame what they like
some of these moves are a little bit
lame because they also pick a fight with
like main main mainstream startups about
giving equity when they're like make
millions if these guys probably make 10
million 15 million a year in profit and
they're very very wealthy and I feel
like it's a little hypocritical
so they on Twitter people are calling
this beef marketing so just have a beef
with everybody just to keep keeping your
keep your name relevant and there's
always gonna be some people that agree
with your side of the story so for
example against the startup industry
they are anti VC don't take funding be
profitable which is weird because
they've taken funding from Jeff Bezos
right but on the whole they they don't
play this or they are profitable and
they don't play these sort of Raisa
ABCDE like sort of get big big big IPO
so they picked that fight they picked
the fight of you don't need to work 80
hours a week
30s enough be productive just be smart
don't kill yourself you don't have to be
working the other day that they are
working through the weekend resolve all
the issues right but I'm saying in
general they've I'm not saying these are
correct I'm saying these are the fights
that they they easily trigger people
just like they triggered you just now
then there's then they also do like they
take summers off which is part of their
kind of like don't be a workaholic thing
and they have one more which is sort of
like don't depend on any platform so
like don't be don't be dependent on
anybody and these funny I get in and I
like a lot of their philosophy I just
think it's stupid what do you make rules
you don't I mean like when you make
rules around something it's like dude
not everything has a rule like a lot of
time like you can't say that you are
anti VC I'm not anti VC at all right I'm
just like Pro like let's be logical and
let's look at a variety of options right
but that doesn't sell right so so if you
just looked at it in terms of like if
they if you just said they're doing all
of this for marketing purposes if you if
you believe that to be true then what
they've done is incredibly effective
it's sort of like buffer right maybe you
don't agree that you should
transparently put all your company
salaries and revenue and losses out
there publicly but if you looked at like
marketing has been undeniably effective
marketing the company no I'm on board I
think look it's working for them I just
think that some of their opinions are
[__] but I like them a lot and I
think that it's incredibly effective for
them so why don't you pick more fights
that was kind of my takeaway when I saw
this I feel like you guys could do way
more of this I think we should and so
like you can't plan right now so I just
picked a fight with the guy today did
you see my Twitter no I didn't what is
it hold on one second economy yeah okay
I'm looking at your Twitter right now so
you picked a fight with this 2vd vld why
it's about the person yeah so what is
this tell me what happened my landing
page they copy drugs completely and I
just they're full of [__] and I emailed
them and tell them to [__] off and they
like try to justify it I'm like no
you're lying like I just looked you up a
web archive you just copied our page
like I see when we launched and then
when you launch you write word for word
ripped us off that's okay so you picked
a fight with them but that's actually uh
if you look at like what the rules are
of this game that's actually a bad fight
you don't pick by example littler than
you you got exactly
well you said New York Times so first I
was thinking cuz you guys have as a
competitor like morning brew right so
like they pretty similar pretty they're
kind of similar size and that's one that
could be more like PewDiePie versity
series where the feud actually would
help both sides grow so that's more like
wrestling where you could be like cool
I'm gonna take you you attack me this is
just gonna generate a bunch of buzz it's
sort of like that barstool color daddy
thing where it's like both sides end up
more popular and through the through the
drama so that's one that I think you
guys could do the other one would be
more like against the mainstream
mainstream media which could be New York
Times now there has to be some level of
authenticity to it so it's got to be
something you genuinely do you believe
like it could be the thing that like why
are you guys pretending like you're not
biased but that doesn't tell a great
story about you guys and what you do
it's not like you guys are like it's not
that the value prop of the Hustle is to
be opinionated clearly and be subjective
not even try to be objective I don't
think that's like what y'all do so yeah
I think you got to pick a fight that a
makes sense
B is polarizing and C somehow tells the
story of what also is all about by being
the opposite of the thing you're hating
on I thought about making front of the
skin because I think they're like a joke
but then I was like I don't know if I
would win that fight yeah I don't know I
think there's something here because I
think in general you do have strong
opinions about things but I don't see
that come through via the hustle maybe
intentionally maybe you've censored it
maybe you haven't but I think no I'm not
censorship how about this let me let me
let me a small tangent something that
I'm we're testing and I'm thinking about
launching is I'm pretty obsessed with
the idea of expert opinion as opposed to
journalist opinion and one thing I'm
testing is I built this network of like
a thousand experts and every day we're
emailing them stories and getting their
opinion and we're gonna just publish
their opinion we're not gonna touch it
when I couldn't edit it we're just gonna
say here's a guy see what they said
right and that's interesting to me and
I'm gonna get people to pay money for it
yeah I think that's actually pretty dope
private Twitter
I saw the like mock-up you guys did I
didn't love that but I love the idea of
this because when I think about it this
actually what I care about I care about
what do the people who actually know
their [__] think about this and not the
journalists with their opinion the
editor with their agenda the journalists
talking to an expert and then like
siphoning off one quote and having that
be you know that fitting into some
narrative I just like let's say it's the
like right now the NBA is about to
resume and there's a big debate should
they come back or should they not come
back some of the players don't want to
come back because of coronavirus some of
the players don't to come back because
it takes away from the black lives
matter movement and there's all these
ESPN Talking Heads
that talk about this like there's
literally this guy Brian Windhorse who's
like you know the opposite of a
basketball player he's like a short fat
white guy who's never played basketball
and he's always talking about what
should happen what shouldn't happen and
I'd rather just be like cool the the
ping goes out to all the NBA players and
here's the 80 responses we got back
LeBron said this I don't know if is
anonymized or if it's with their name
but
would be way more interesting to me it's
like here's what they actually think
yeah so that's what I'm thinking about
building or that's what we're attempting
to build and and in that case the enemy
to me is clear it's just like journalism
as a whole journalism because yeah what
do you think about it like we don't need
you a little bit phone is a journalist
and I hate when here I I hate the fact
that journalists journalism is a circle
jerk on Twitter like they only want to
impress each other they don't want to
impress their audiences like you have to
like what I tell our team I'm like guys
we don't serve each other we serve our
readers like we are their waiters we are
their servants we exist to give them
information and my team who has worked
at a variety of places are like well
that's so different than other places
because it's all about how do we win
awards or how do we do this for that and
I'm like yeah that baffles me that that
is the thing so that's our enemy for
that yeah okay I like that
I think that could be good cool pick a
fight I like I have another random idea
or thing to talk about so we both like
this comedian Chris D'Elia and he was
funny guy we thought he was great the
bad I'll speak for myself yeah I don't
know I don't know you felt but we
thought he was hilarious
whatever he's a comedian I thought he
was the best I've seen him live a couple
times and I listened to his podcast a
bunch that's one of the few podcasts I
listened to anyways last week gets
exposed as sort of like a creep and so a
bunch of people come out and say hey of
course D'Elia was messaging me when I
was you know 17 16 years old and asking
me for nude pictures and all asbestos
right so whole bunch people come out at
once turns out Chris D'Elia is creeping
around or allegedly creeping around and
so this comes out he's sort of getting
cancelled right now so two questions for
you our question for you what was your
reaction when that happened and then I
have an idea based on that my reaction
was if I was even bummed that he was
accused and the evidence was damn strong
prions oh I believe it to be true and in
my head I think well [__] you like
you're here the
worse so I feel pissed off because I I
was a huge huge huge fan and I I don't
know I'll still listen to his jokes but
I will not like support him financially
yes that was my other question well if
you're listening to him you're still
supporting him in some way I guess no
but I don't know if I would pay money to
go see him right so that's got my other
question is and nobody really talks
about this it's sort of like cool I'm a
fan or you're cancelled but I think in
reality you know as so many people this
is you know two of my favorite comedians
Louie CK and Chris D'Elia
both came out to be doing really creepy
messed up behavior but there's also
people who are clearly still fans of
Lucy kay they're probably not fans of
what he did but they're still fans of
him though so listen to his stuff
they'll go to his shows and I was
wondering how do you deal with that kind
of like being torn between like well you
don't like what they did and maybe you
don't even like the person but you kind
of like their art you know like I don't
know people still feel like so like you
know yeah I still watch The Cosby Show I
listened to our Kelly I love Michael
Jackson music here's my logic right
here's here with great people people who
achieve greatness who are like
world-class at the crafts are nine out
of ten times [__] weird and hopefully
only weird sometimes they're also bad
people right and I just accept that like
the people who I like are also good
there's a great quote where it says like
every great man's a bad man and in this
case it is incredibly true we're like
he's with all this great stuff
he just has also done a ton of bad [__]
so I still like will absolutely listen
to his stuff but I won't I think he's a
piece of [__] right isn't that weird
that's I'm sort of in the same boat I
don't know how to feel is that's why I
brought it up cuz I'm not weird
I mean if you like surely like there's
some like like I don't know I don't even
like it in political but maybe like
chicken like chick-fil-a it's like dude
my taste buds don't know that you hate
gays right right right
oh it's like I couldn't it's hard you
know I could I could disagree with you I
would still enjoy your stuff right yeah
and I think I mean with
with all with all that's coming out
everybody's gonna have to figure out how
they're gonna deal with this because
your favorite something musician athlete
comedian politician one of your
favorites is gonna go down for being a
total either [__] creep criminal bad
guy you know something's gonna come out
and I think everybody have to ask
themselves cool how am I gonna deal with
that am I gonna still consume their
stuff that I like or am I gonna protest
it am I gonna think they're a piece of
[__] am I gonna be conflicted what's
gonna happen it's like it's like you
know Martin Luther King's one of my
heroes but he also cheated on his wife a
lot right oh that's like the rumor um so
it's like what heard about that's really
crazy apparently I just learned about
this but like the FBI was tracking him
for a while because he was seen as sort
of like a potential enemy of the state
and they like bugged his hotel rooms or
whatever there's reportedly no one's
seen this I guess but it's there's
reportedly tapes of him sleeping with
like 40 different women you know outside
of his marriage and participating and
you know some sort of sexually deviant
activities but he's Martin Luther
[__] King right he's got like you
know a day a day named after him and
everything else yeah so that's what my
opinion is just like everyone who's
great is also bad in another person's
perspective and you just you just got to
take the whole person right okay so the
idea I had off this was actually a
WikiLeaks for creeps because one of the
things that was really disturbing that
came out of this was not just oh this
guy I thought was cool light turns out
to be not so cool and I don't like what
he did it was like a lot of these text
messages were from like 10 plus years
ago and so and same thing with like a
lot of people that get canceled like the
Bill Cosby stuff a lot of that stuff I
think what's happening like in that 90s
or something like that and it takes
sometimes decades for the stuff to come
out and I think that's a shame because
you know a the person sort of gets away
with it and continues to harm other
people or sort of you know be you know a
menace in society is out on the loose as
long as these things stay secret but I
understand why people don't expose
things and they get tied up and wrapped
up in it and you know you can see the
girls who came out and said something
about Chris D'Elia their Twitter they're
getting attacked by his fans who are
like you know well why'd you why'd you
send him the picture and like stupid
stuff like that and so I think there
needs to be sort of a WikiLeaks
for creeps where there is a there is a
way to dump anonymously evidence and
claims against people and then there
needs to be some sort of like verifying
function like a set of journalists kind
of like the people who went and studied
the Panama papers and like dug into me
to try to figure out which what's real
what's not but like a guaranteed sort of
anonymity layer so that you know
information can get out faster what do
you think of that as long as there's a
trustworthy third party to verify I've
been to it it's just so easy to accuse
people of doing bad stuff totally and
that's the reason this can't be a
company cuz you'll just die of sort of
libel and slander you know like because
anything that turns out not to be true
you get to get sued out of existence I
think there was like a there was an app
that used to rape guys I think it's
called Lola or Lala I remember that this
I remember that I my roommate was rated
on it and it said like not just cheated
on me and like small dick I was like oh
dude that sucks like I'm sorry so yeah
like I think you can't really do this as
a company but I think for society it
would be good if there's a way for
people to be able to come forward about
bad behavior better for a whistleblower
network to come forward and not just
about like how WikiLeaks is about sort
of documents around certain things but
actually around you know racism sexual
harassment things like that I think
there needs to be something like this
obviously I haven't put a lot of thought
into this I'm not an expert about the
stuff but when I saw this ten years to
come out I'm like something's broken
yeah it is crazy that like Hannibal
Buress joked about that Bill Cosby thing
in his joke with something like what
everyone knows this everyone knows this
guy Harvey Weinstein everybody knew that
like everyone we all talked about this
we all know this it's like whoa what I
didn't know this this is crazy
like I wish I would have I agree with
that I also think that there's a lot of
room to deconstruct Wikipedia
I think Wikipedia is I I'm like I
wouldn't say I'm a hardcore libertarian
but I'm libertarian or I tend to be on a
lot of topics and I think that Wikipedia
should actually
the nonprofit or some type of like owned
by the government and should be a good
national treasure that yet the
Department of Education should just own
Wikipedia and fund it through yeah what
does the brain look up the Department of
Education funding and I bet that would
cover you know ease easily what
Wikipedia needs to stay around and it's
doing a hell of a lot more than the
Department of Education probably is will
compete already and it might see a
non-profit but I want to make sure it
never goes out of business I think that
Wikipedia is a treasure it's same with
wicket I'm like reddit don't make money
you don't need to make money well you
just asked to put a little donation
thing and just let us see your expenses
and I'll just give you a little bit and
everyone will it's like one of the few
things where I'm like donation or
government funding is the way to go
right on okay I want to give people in
the last four minutes oh my god
Department of Education 68 billion in
funding yeah they could afford to how
much you think Wikipedia I don't even
know I mean if you're if you have five
billion page views a month how much will
they say on their thing we need this
much to survive I don't know what it is
but it's like it's not work I don't
think it's above two billion I don't
think I don't even know later that what
do you think twitch costs to run like I
can't say okay if I heard just for the
hosting like I'm ignorant I know nothing
does it cost more than 10 million do you
think it would cost more than 10 million
a month yes
can't say about twitch but I would just
say I'm sorry Wikipedia you think
Wikipedia cost 110 million dollars a
month just in hosting I think it's
probably about that that'd be my guess
so they do $200 a year the AWS could
just fund it okay this is powered by AWS
it could be on every page powered by AWS
free hosting that way
Wikipedia's fundings around a hundred
million year there it is okay so I let's
give him one more idea before we go
because we talked about a bunch of
random topics today okay business idea
so I just got my new house and I'm
renting this place and as part of it you
need renter's insurance and something
like oh [__] here's a task I don't want
to go do yeah go get lemonade yeah I
gotta go do whatever but I was thinking
about it I was like in the guy who's
telling me I need renter's insurance is
the broker the agent who like rented me
the house and I was like why isn't this
just part of the lease where like you're
like hey by the way check this box
because you need renter's insurance to
just do it through me and you have your
register sure it's done and so obviously
this guy's not an insurance company but
what I think you could do is create a
back office insurance company or the
storefront is actually just all the
rental agents and brokers that already
are talking to the customer just signed
the deal they're the ones trying to
enforce these terms and force you to
have insurance
why aren't they empowered so I'll give
you an example of this I have a buddy
named guy gal great name [__] top
five name guy gal guy gal is his name
that's great and guy has this company
yeah Rhys I believe is the name of the
company and what he does is he's like
hey you know all these when you go to
sell a house and the sign goes up and
it's like Coldwell Banker or like yeah
whatever
KP homes or whatever it is it's like oh
is the brokerage name and then like the
agent is kind of like a very secondary
footer thing he's like dude the the
world is shifting where the agents
really want their own brand upfront the
agents are the one who go do the
marketing to sales so what he did was
he's like he goat and the broker takes a
huge fee so when an agent gets their fee
I think the broker should take 50% and
so he's like look through technology I
can make a more streamlined brokerage
and what I could do is I can be a hit in
back-office for any agent so you're the
agent your name is
Alex you know Alex from Perot well you
could just be the wrong pero group and
you could build your brand as the as the
storefront forget Coldwell Banker you
don't need those guys I will be the the
back-office I'll take care of the legal
compliance and paperwork that the
brokerage normally does and I will only
charge you X percent fee and it's much
less than the fifty percent that goes
ask you a call ball banker does Kalb a
bigger does it but they are the
back-office but they put their brand
first and a broker can't Riedel I kind
of put their own marketing front on top
but it's not their core model and they
take a huge cut so what this guy did
what he did with rise is really smart he
he targeted the top 1% of agents in
every market he goes to them he said
you're at top 1% you don't need Coldwell
Banker you are the brand and he said
bring your book of business to me I'll
do the same work that they do for you
with the lower cut and I'm gonna look
you push a button your website gets
split up automatically I'll take care of
all your sort of technology needs and I
take fifteen percent isn't fifty percent
or whatever it is and so I think it's
really smart model he's doing really was
he doing I can't say but the company's
doing well and I think it's a really
smart model attacking a very big space
which is this back-end brokerage thing
for home sales I think you could do the
same thing for insurance I think you
could build an invisible insurance
company and have the brokers or the
agents be the storefront and just say
hey you should just offer this to all
your clients when they rent from you or
buy from you but why wouldn't lemonade
or all of these companies go to those
guys and do this they could I don't know
maybe they maybe they will I'm not sure
but I know that compass kind of did this
in the real estate space I know that
there's this awesome company I really
wanted to invest in called
what is it called damn I forget the name
but there's somebody doing this for
business insurance where they where
they're trying to be a back office as a
service I've seen that I think there's
more that I think there's more companies
that can do this that are not doing this
today where you empower the agent who is
already at the point of sale and you
give them a thing to upsell that gives
them a little bit of money and it makes
your customer acquisition free and you
just need to provide the backend service
for it so I think there's a whole class
of businesses like this yeah I need to
go and research all this I'm this in
this interests me a lot I'm gonna go
look up
well banker I believe I see their signs
don't even what they do entirely yeah
deep dive it and deep dive compass cuz
they kind of disrupted the family crush
it
all right I gotta run my computer
battery's at 1% by the way Michael
Bisping
oh I Bri abrazos compass is BS Michael
Bisping what's to come on the podcast
you want um yes alone please be it'd be
great down I'm gonna shut my computer I
gotta go see you
[Music]
[Applause]